THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SERVICES WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE IN RESPONSE
BECOME A NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERING SENATORS SOCIAL
DISTANCING. AND FEES COVERING
GUIDELINES AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LOOK. TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE ARE
HOLDING OUR HEARINGS HERE IN
THE- STREET BUILDING I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BE
PRESIDENT BROUGH. BUT WITH
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED. FOR TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED SO WE CAN ESTABLISH
A QUORUM AND BEGIN OUR HEARING.
AND WITH YOU PLEASE NOT FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WHO DO HAVE A
ROOM CHANGE WE WILL BE MEETING A
ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED THEY
JUST ANNOUNCED RATHER THAN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED SO TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY. UGH DUE TO A
ROOM CHANGE TO ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED FOR TODAY'S HEARING B.
LISTEN ONLY LINE FOR THIS
HEARING IS. ONE EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT ZERO EIGHT SIX NINE.
TWO NINE. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN THREE SIX TWO EIGHT
THREE THREE. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS ONE EIGHT. SEVEN SEVEN TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE FIVE
THREE ZERO ZERO ZERO SIX. UP FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND-
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. I WOULD
REMOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR TO
TELL ONE AND ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME
AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATIVE SIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER
THIS CAN BE SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT. IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
A MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOT PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER
FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
TO WHAT ACOSTA FEEDBACK YOU MUST
MEET THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING
FIGURINE ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL MAINTAIN A DECORUM.
DURING THE HEARING AS A CUSTOMER
AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WAS
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS- MUTED.
TODAY WE HAVE FIVE ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA. THE FOLLOWING TWO ITEMS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR S. B.
ELEVEN THIRTY FOUR BY SENATOR
MELENDEZ AT S. B. FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE BY SENATOR JONES.
THIS MEANS WE WILL HEAR A TOTAL
OF THREE ITEMS TODAY. AND. WE
HAVE AN AUTHOR PRESENT WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM AT THE MOMENT SO
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN AT
ESTABLISH QUORUM A DUMB DUMB
DOWN THE LINE UP AND THE SENATOR
SKINNER YOUR CARE TO PRESENT.
TWO THREE AND. WE DO KNOW. AT
AND AS SENATORS GONNA BEFORE YOU
BEGIN I'D LIKE TO ESTABLISH
QUORUM. HER DAUGHTER PRESENT FOR
DATA PRESENT JONES. CREDIBLY
YOUR FOR THE YEAR KAMLAGER THE
MOTHER HERE TEN PRESENT CAN
PRESENT. WHAT HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED CENTRES COMMITTEE
MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SB. TEN
EIGHTY THREE. AND UNFORTUNATELY
GROWING NUMBER OF FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN WHO ARE LIVING ON OUR
STREETS YOU YOU'RE NOT HAVE
HOUSING AND ADDITIONALLY-
PREGNANT PEOPLE SO WHAT SB TEN
EIGHTY THREE DOES IS EXPEDITE.
THEIR ACCESS TO TEMPORARY HOTEL
VOUCHERS AND THEN EXTENDS THE
TIME THAT SUCH A FAMILY CAN STAY
IN THE TEMPORARY HOTEL SO THAT.
THEY HAVE ENOUGH TIME WITH THE
SOCIAL WORKER WHOEVER'S
ASSISTING THEM TO SECURE THAT
PERMANENT HOUSING THERE'S A VERY
INTERESTING- SERIES- I BELIEVE
IT'S- I IT WAS- FUNDED AND SET
UP BY PBS. THAT SESAME STREET
PRODUCED AND IT'S HEARING FROM
KIDS DIRECTLY AND EACH SEGMENT
IS ABOUT A KIDS EXPERIENCE A ONE
SEGMENT IS KIDS WHO ARE ON
CHILDREN OF VETERANS ANOTHER
SEGMENT IS KIDS WHO ARE CHILDREN
OF INCARCERATED PEOPLE IN
ANOTHER SEGMENT IS CHILDREN WHO
ARE HOMELESS. AND THE IT'S VERY
POWERFUL BUT THE TRAGEDY OF
WATCHING IT IS THERE'S MANY ON
SCENES WHERE THE KIDS ARE IN THE
HOTEL ROOM WHERE THEY HAVE THIS
TEMPORARY AND THEY'RE BEING ABLE
TO GO TO SCHOOL AND THEY WERE
GETTING BACK IN THERE DOING
THEIR HOMEWORK BUT THEN THEIR
VOUCHER RUNS OUT. AND THEY'RE
BACK IN THEIR CAR IN THE NEAR IT
MOVE AROUND SO MUCH THAT THEY
CAN'T GO TO THE SAME SCHOOL OR
THE SOCIAL WORKERS TRYING TO
HELP THEM CAN'T FIND SO THIS
BILL WOULD ADDRESS THAT AND
ALLOW ME GO TO MY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. AND THEY ARE- SKEWS ME
UP. HI WE HAVE BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS AND WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY. WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO- JUST MONEY AND
SUPPORT. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY
CAROL WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WE- STANDARD IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN
EIGHTY THREE APPRECIATE THE
SENATOR'S EFFORTS TO BRING THIS
FORWARD- THIS LAWS BEEN ON THE
BOOKS FOR A LONG TIME THIS WAS
ACTUALLY WESTERN CENTER LAWSUIT
BACK IN LATE NINETEEN EIGHTIES
NEGOTIATED OUT UNDER FORMER
GOVERNOR PETE WILSON. AND AT THE
TIME THAT THIS LAW WAS PASSED IN
DECEMBER SOME GOOD STUFF BUT
ALSO HAVE SOME SIGNIFICANT
LIMITATIONS NOW OVER THE YEARS
WE'VE BEEN ABLE WITH THE HELP OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO GET SOME
CHANGES TO THE PROGRAM SENATOR
SKINNER'S BILL HOWEVER REALLY
TAKES THIS TO THE NEXT LEVEL AND
MAKES LONG OVERDUE CHANGES THAT
ARE REALLY BADLY NEEDED. FIRST
OF ALL IT WOULD ALLOW COUNTIES
TO BE ABLE PROVIDED ASSISTANCE
AT THE FIRST IMPLICATION OF
HOMELESSNESS ON THE HORIZON YOU
WON'T HAVE TO WAIT FOR A THREE
DAY NOTICE BEFORE WE CAN PROVIDE
SERVICES AS WE HAVE FOR SO MANY
PEOPLE AND FOR MANY PEOPLE THEY
LOSE THEIR HOUSING BECAUSE BY
THAT POINT IT'S TOO LATESO
THAT'S A VERY SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
WE ALSO ALLOW PEOPLE TO GET UP
TO FORTY DAYS OF ASSISTANCE
THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN A TIME
WHEN SIXTEEN DAYS WOULD WORK IN
THE OLD HOUSING CAP IN THE
WORLD. CALIFORNIA HOUSING MARKET
NOT IN TODAY'S HOUSING MARKET
YOU NEED MORE TIME TO GET
ASSISTANCE AND THEN FRANKLY AND
THEN FINALLY- THIS BILL ALSO-
EXPANDS THE POTENTIAL RESOURCES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE- FOR THE
PROGRAM ELIMINATES THE ONCE AND-
YEAH I YEAR PROHIBITION- ON
GETTING- ASSISTANCE FOR THIS AS
WE KNOW UNFORTUNATELY SOME
FAMILIES HAVE MULTIPLE INCIDENTS
OF HOMELESSNESS AND WE NEED TO
BE PREPARED TO HELP THEM AT ALL
TIMES FOR ALL THESE REASONS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TEN EIGHTY
THREE. THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE
ANOTHER THE OTHER WITNESSES ON
THE PHONE LINE. AN OPERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE FOR
THE WITNESS. HI HI THERE ARE
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. A GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU MANAGER COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS A NUMBER OF THE ACCOUNT
AND ALSO. WANT TO SEE WHAT ONES
AFTER PROJECT WHERE REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE DEBATE WORK. WITH
OFFICES IN ANGELES STOCKTON AND
WE'RE COMMITTED TO AND YOUR
OVERALL HEALTH STATUS WILL BE
BLACK GIRL SH ALCOVE. I WOULD
LIKE TO OUR STRONG AND SUPPORT
AND TWENTY THREE THE HELP
FAMILIES OUT OF HOMES ACT WHICH
MAKES CRITICAL AND- CAL WORKED
PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT PREGNANT
WITH OF A WHO AT RISK OF
RECRUITING EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. ALL THE PEOPLE ARE
DESERVING OF DIGNITY IN THEIR-
AND BIRTHING. THIS INCLUDES THE
WHO ARE OF CURRENT WITH OF
RECURRENT. EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. AND CITY THE U.
MORE THAN TWO THIRDS PERCENT
ACTUALLY PEOPLE HOMELESSNESS AND
PAM. IDENTIFIED BLACK IN LOS
ANGELES TWELVE POINT SIX PER OF
BLAH WOMEN A WREATH LIFE
REPORTED WORKING.
BLACK MOMS AND BABIES ALREADY
DISPROPORTIONATE RISK OF ADVERSE
BIRTH OUTCOMES THE FACT OF BEING
HOMELESS CAN ONLY FUNCTION TO
EXACERBATE THE ALREADY DIRE.
THIS WE KNOW THE STRUCTURAL
INEQUITIES IN ECONOMIC INJUSTICE
CONTRIBUTE TO ACTIVATE THE
HEALTH. THE BLACK WOMEN OTHER
DISPROPORTIONATELY. IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES BEAR. BILL RESPOND
IN MEETING THAT TO HELP MITIGATE
THE IMPACT BE THE NEXT MEANS
PUBLIC INTEREST DUE TO. FOR
COMMUNITY EXPERIENCING HOME.
THANK SO BY ENSURING THAT PEOPLE
IN THE FAMILY DO NOT WITHOUT
SHELTER OF. WHILE ALSO AVAILABLE
A CRITICAL SERVICE THE COUNTY
MIDDLE HOMES PRO FOR ELIGIBLE
RECIPIENTS. THIS ARMS RACE WILL
HOUSING CRITICAL WILL HELP THE
PARTY BEING POSITIVE BURKE
OUTCOMES. BUT IN. FOR TOO MANY
PARTS PEOPLE FAMILY LOOKING
CHILDREN TO HAVE AN- WE SEE THE
GROW FIFTY FIRST. MARKET YEARS
LACK TO. REPRESENTED IN MORE AND
MORE OF THE SHOULDERS LIKE THE
PEOPLE WITH THIS BILL KELLER
WOULD BUILD ON PROGRAMS ENSURE
THAT PREGNANT PEOPLE YOU FAMILY
. AT THE HOUSE. THIS BOLSTERS
CRITICAL SUPPORT FOR PEOPLE YOUR
FAMILY COMPLETE PEACE OF THE FOR
THEM TO MAKE BEST THIS FOR THEIR
- HAVE PROBLEMS OR THE BEST TEN
EIGHTY. I RESPECT URGE YOU TO
VOTE YES ON BILL THANK YOU.
TIME I JUST WANT TO RE EMPHASIZE
THAT ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY WILL- LIMIT IF YOU CAN
PLEASE LIMIT TO YOUR COMMENTS TO
NAME AFFILIATION A POSITION ON
THE MEASURE. AND WILL BEGIN WITH
WITNESSES HERE IN THE ROOM- TO
TESTIFY ON. SENATE BILL TEN
EIGHTY THREE. AND FEEL PLEASE
BEGIN GOOD AFTERNOON KEVIN AS
THE COLDEST OF CALIFORNIA BEFORE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS. AND WITH
THIS BILL WAS OFFICIALLY PASSED.
WHO THERE WAS NO LIMITATION TO
HOW MANY TIMES TO GET GET GET
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE. AND THEN
UNDER TRAILER BILL THEY MADE
ONCE IN A LIFETIME. A FIVE YEAR
BECAUSE FIVE YEARS AGO UNDER
BROWN ADMINISTRATION WE MAY WANT
TO HEAR. ENOUGH THIS WOULD GO
BACK TO ITS ORIGINAL FORMAT THE
WAY IT WAS THANK YOU SIR WITH
PASSED THE NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
YES LONG SUPPORT THANK THANK YOU
REPEAT IT JUST A REMINDER IF YOU
COULD JUST PLEASE LET LIMIT-
YOUR COMMENTS TO NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. I THANK HIM LUIS
REPRESENTING NOW IN SUPPORT. YOU
CAN. THANK YOU FOR ASKING AND I
WITH THE WEST SORRY KP PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF THE NURSE
FAMILY PARTNERSHIP PARENTS
STRONG SUPPORT. OKAY ANY
ADDITIONAL. PEOPLE OKAY NOW
FINAN THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELEPHONE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS. MODERATOR CAN YOU ACT
LIKE WILL YOU NOW ASK ALL
INDIVIDUALS WERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. DEREK WAS TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND FOR US TO GO
TO LINE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KAREN MEMBERS KATHY MARC BERMAN
NURSE CALIFORNIA INSTRUCT THE
PORT AND EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO GO TO
LINE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ERIN EVANS
ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. AND I COULD LINE FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS MOLLY
SHEEHAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB TEN EIGHTY THREE
THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO GO TO
LINE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MARK HUGHES ON BEHALF OF FIRST
FIVE CALIFORNIA INTO COURT THANK
YOU. THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. J.
CALCANEAL CALIFORNIA LINES OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THE NEXT TO GO
TO LINE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
GUARDIAN RIGHT THE BIRTH EQUITY
ADVOCACY PROJECT IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
A SHAMAN THROUGHOUT RAMIS WE
CONSUMER WATCHDOG I SENT A
LETTER SUPPORT WE SUPPORT SB TEN
EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT TO A COUPLE LINE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI AT
HELLO SENATORS AND SINGLE MOM
SAVE A FAMILY DEMI MALACHI
STARVATION STRONGLY SUPPORTED IN
HONOR OF THE I MEAN I. THANK YOU
. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
WELL OVER DOUBLE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS J. R. H. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. JANNA
RIGHT WITH LA BETHANY'S NETWORK
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TO
THIS TIME THERE'S NO OTHERS IN
Q. OKAY. THANK YOU AND WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY SCHEDULE LEAD WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL SO.
IF THERE'S ANYONE WISHING TO-
PROVIDE THE COMMENTS THE NAME
AFFILIATION A POSITION ON THIS
BILL IN OPPOSITION OF IT- LET'S
BEGIN WITH THOSE INDIVIDUALS
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
ANYONE KNOW KICKIN ARE AND- CAN
WE PLEASE MOVE ON TO WITNESSES-
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL ON
THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT
LINE. IF YOU LOOK COMMON
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN EIGHT THREE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU- SENATOR
SKINNER FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD TO IMPROVE THE PROGRAM
THAT AFFECTS SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES PREGNANT AND
HOMELESS FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN
. I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
TO ADDRESS TECHNICAL AND
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES. AND I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU CONTINUE
WORKING WITH BOTH THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE COUNTIES TO WORK OUT
THESE TECHNICAL OUR CONCERNS.
ARE DO WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT. CENTERPOINT THANK YOU AND US
ARE SKINNER REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AND CERTAINLY GREE WITH- WHAT
YOU'RE PROPOSING AND THE BILL
LIKE IT DID HAVE A QUESTION IN
TERMS OF CAPACITY AND I DON'T
KNOW WHAT DO YOU HAVE AN ANSWER
TO THIS THE- SO CERTAINLY I
THINK IT MAKES. SENSE FOR
EVERYTHING THAT YOU SAID THAT-
TEST FIRE SAID AT TERMS OF
HAVING MORE TIME. FOR PEOPLE-
BUT I GUESS I'M ALSO WHETHER YOU
CAN COMMENT ON BOTH- HOW DO WE
HAVE THE SHELTER CAPACITY ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO AND- WE
THINKING ABOUT PROVIDING- OUR
LOW SUPPORT WE CAN PROVIDE
LOCALITIES TO HAVE THAT FILTER
TO PASSAGE AND I PEOPLE STAYING
LONGER FOR ALL THE GOOD REASONS
YOU POINTED OUT. THAT HE NEEDS A
LONGER OBVIOUSLY GO WE'VE BEEN
WORKING IN THE SENATE- TO.
ACTUALLY PROVE OVERALL HOUSING
OVER ALSO IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
SHELTERS BUT CLEARLY THAT TERMS
OF THIS POPULATION WITH THIS
BILL I GET THE MORE PRESSURE ON
SHELTER CAPACITY RIGHT TO SINCE
WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE STAY LONGER-
SO COULD HE MAYBE. WERE THERE
CAN YOU PERHAPS ADDRESS THAT IN
TERMS OF- IT'S NOT PART OF THE
BILL BUT PERHAPS THERE'S OTHER
THINGS YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT OR
SUCH OTHER CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
INSURING THAT- THIS IS A DIGITAL
NOW BECOMES LAW THAT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE THE SHELTER CAPACITY TO
ALLOW PEOPLE TO STAY THAT PERIOD
OF TIME- OR WE GET YOU KNOW
WITHOUT FORCING OTHER PEOPLE. TO
BASICALLY NOT BILL TO GET INTO
THE SHELTER. YOU ALSO COULD USE
ASSISTANCE. CERTAINLY THROUGH
THE CHAIR. YES THANK YOU FROM.
SO BILL ABOUT THE SOUTH AND NOT
THE SHORTER AND THE IS BE. PART
OF THE PART THE PROBLEM WITH THE
SHELTER SYSTEM IS THAT LET'S
TAKE- YOU'VE GOT FEMALE SOLDIERS
MAIL SHELTER SO YOU'RE YOU'RE A
FAMILY WITH KIDS AND YOU HAVE A
SON THAT'S TWELFTH IN IN-
MOTIONAL TO RULES WOULDN'T ALLOW
THE TWELVE YEAR OLD MALE TO GO
INTO THE WITH FEMALE SHELTER SO
THE FAMILY THEN REFUSES TO GO TO
SHELTER BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT
TO SEE THEIR CHILDREN SEPARATED.
SO THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS
FOCUSED ON VOUCHERS FOR ITS
USUALLY IN- THERE ARE SOME
PROGRAMS THAT AREN'T HOTEL OR
MOTEL THERE'S SOME YOU KNOW
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING THAT THE
VOUCHERS WOULD BE APPLIED FOR
BUT IT'S NOT FOR TRADITIONAL
SHELTER. AND AS WE ARE PUTTING
MORE MONEY INTO THINGS LIKE
PROJECT- ROOM KEY AND SUCH WHILE
IT'S CERTAINLY YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
CLEAR THAT WILL DO THAT
UNLIMITED LEE WE AT THE MOMENT
HAVE MORE CAPACITY TO GIVE
PEOPLE VOUCHERS FOR LONGER AND
THEN YOU KNOW WHAT PART OF MY
THINKING AND TRYING TO DO THIS
RIGHT NOW IS THAT WE ARE FUNDING
VOUCHERS AND WE ARE FINDING
PERMANENT HOUSING. AND SO IF WE
HAVE A FAMILY IN A IN A IN THE
TEMPORARY MAYBE WE WILL CONNECT
THEM TO THAT NEW HOUSING QUICKER
AND. THEY SHOULD HAVE A PRIORITY
FOR IT ANYWAY. NO THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THE ANSWER AND
CERTAINLY THEY THINK THAT IS THE
HOPE RIGHT THAT RADIO. GIVE
PEOPLE THE TIME AND YOU MADE
THAT- YOU HAVE SAID THAT THE
TESTIMONY THAT. SIXTY DAYS MAYBE
TOO SHORT TO ACTUALLY MAKE THAT
CONNECTION YEAH AND THEN YOU
LOSE THE FAMILY ON THE STREETS
RIGHT AGAIN INSTEAD OF BEING
ABLE TO STILL CONNECT THEM AND
GET THEM INTO A PERMIT HOUSING
SOLUTIONS. RIGHT THANK YOU AND
I'D LIKE TO MOVE TO BUILD
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU I
HAVE IF YOU HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. NO OKAY SO WE
HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL
CENTERS CAN WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU SO MUCH- MANAGER AND
YES I WILL ABSOLUTELY COMMIT TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WE WANT THIS
TO WORK AND WE KNOW. I'VE
ALREADY HAD THE EXPERIENCE WHERE
YOU KNOW OUT GOOD BILLS WERE
PASSED THAT DIDN'T REALLY GET
IMPLEMENTED IN THE WAY INTENDED
BECAUSE THERE WASN'T CAPACITY OR
THERE WERE OBSTACLES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT'S. HUNT MAYBE THEY
HADN'T IDENTIFIED IN ADVANCE BUT
WE HADN'T WORKED CLEAR ENOUGH TO
SEE SO. THAT WITH THAT
EXPERIENCE I DEFINITELY WANT TO
HAVE THE DEPARTMENT'S HELP US
IDENTIFY WHAT OBSTACLES OR THE
COUNTIES. SO THAT WE CAN TWEAK
IT BECAUSE WE WANT TO WORK THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND WITH
THAT I ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU. I
SO HAVE A MOTION ON SB TEN
EIGHTY THREE- BY SENATOR HAND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST
RE RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CONSULTING HE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HURTADO I
HURDLE I JONES HI JONES I
CRITICALLY EARLY FOR THE AYE
KAMAGRA AYE GALLAGHER AYE. HI.
FIVE ZERO THE BILL IS FIVE ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT. CONGRATULATIONS
OKAY. ALL RIGHT AND- SINCE WE
HAVE A STOP SCORM EVERYBODY'S
HERE WAITING ON CENTER BATES TO
ARRIVE TO PRESENT I'D LIKE TO
TAKE UP- BILLS THAT ARE ON
PLEASE OF CALL THE ROLL ON THOSE
. MBANK THE CONTENT FILER SB.
ONE ONE THREE FOUR BY SENATOR
MELENDEZ AT THE OF FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE BY SENATOR JOHN.
HURTADO I FIR DATA I JONES.
JONES I'D COURTESY. FOR THE ALLY
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER I PAN HI
CAN I. VOTED FIVE ZERO. AND THE
BILLS ON CONSENT ARE OUT.
RIGHT THANK YOU CENTER BATES
YOU'RE YOU'RE UP TO PUT. YEAH
COME ON UP. SLOCUM CENTER BAY TO
MAKE ISN'T YOUR BILL S. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY TWO. SO THIS IS
SB THIRTEEN FORTY TWO A GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR HER TADO AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM VERY
PLEASED TO PRESENT S. B. R.
THIRTEEN FORTY TWO WHICH WOULD
AUTHORIZE COUNTIES TO CREATE
MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAMS FOR
OLDER ADULTS. ADULTS ARE TO
BEGIN IT'S REALLY WANT TO THANK
YOU AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ALL OF THE WORK THEY HAVE PUT
INTO MAKING THIS BILL WORK THE
FASTEST GROWING DEMOGRAPHICS IN
CALIFORNIA IS OLDER ADULTS. BY
TWENTY THIRTY ONE QUARTER OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION WILL BE
SIXTY OR OLDER. A RECENT SCANNED
FOUNDATION POLL REPORTED THAT
NEARLY 40% OF CALIFORNIANS OVER
THE AGE OF SIXTY FOUR WHO LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY STATED THEY NEED
HELP WITH THEIR DAILY ACTIVITIES
SUCH AS RUNNING ERRANDS BEATING
DRESSING ANNUAL PREPARATION.
HOWEVER AGING SERVICES ARE
FRACTURED BY AN ARBITRARY
DIVISION OF EXPERTISE IN
PROGRAMS CERTAINLY KIND OF LIKE
PROGRAM SILOS ON THE ONE HAND
THIS ALLOWS FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
OF QUALITY SERVICES AND SKILLED
STAFF BUT ON THE OTHER IT
CREATES GAPS IN INEFFICIENCIES
THAT CAN ONLY BE RESOLVED WITH
THESE AGENCIES ARE ALLOWED TO
WORK TOGETHER. BY AUTHORIZING
COUNTIES TO CREATE A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM FOR OLDER
ADULTS AGING SERVICE PROVIDER
AGENCIES CAN SHARE INFORMATION
TO HOLISTICALLY ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF THIS SEGMENT OF THE
POPULATION. THEY WILL ALSO BE
ABLE TO DEVELOP COORDINATED CASE
PLANS IMPROVE SERVICE DELIVERY
AND PROVIDE SUPPORT TO
CAREGIVERS THE CURRENT SYSTEM
DOES NOT ALLOW FOR THE
COORDINATION OF SERVICES AMONG
AGING SERVICE PROVIDER AGENCIES
DUE TO LEGAL CONSTRAINTS. ON THE
SHARING OF INFORMATION THE
RESULT IS OLDER ADULTS ARE
SUBJECTED TO LENGTHY AND OFTEN
REDUNDANT INTAKE PROCESS SEES
THAT REQUIRE THEM TO REPEAT
THEIR STORY TO EACH NEW PROVIDER
. WHILE MOST OLDER ADULTS WERE
FULLY CAPABLE OF ADVOCATING FOR
THEMSELVES SB THIRTEEN FORTY TO
SEEK TO SUPPORT THOSE WHO NEED
ASSISTANCE NAVIGATING THE
COMPLEX NETWORK. OF SERVICES
AVAILABLE IN THEIR AREA IT
BRINGS THE EXPERTS AND PROGRAMS
TOGETHER TO BETTER SERVE OUR
AGING ADULT POPULATION IN THE
CARE GIVERS WHO OVERSEE THEM.
THE MEASURE WOULD REPLACE A LONG
STANDING REACTIVE APPROACH TO
OLDER ADULT CARE COORDINATION
WITH THE NEW PROACTIVE ONE
OFFERING COMPREHENSIVE AND
COLLABORATIVE STRATEGIES TO
DELIVER AGING SERVICES THE BILL
IS SPONSORED. BY THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE AND SUPPORTED BY C. SACK
CW L. C. W. D. A. AND A NUMBER
OF NONPROFITS THIS EFFORT IS
BEING LED BY THE PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND. DOING THIS MOST
IMPORTANT WORK AND I'M HONORED
TO BE THE AUTHOR HERE TO TESTIFY
ON BEHALF. OF THE BILL OUR
DEBORAH BATES NO RELATIONSHIP.
ORANGE COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICE
AGENCY DIRECTOR IN HOLLY HAGLER
CEO FOR MEALS ON WHEELS ORANGE
COUNTY. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE HER
CALDERON COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'VE
NEVER BATES DIRECTOR OF
ACCOUNTING A BORN SOCIAL
SERVICES AGENCY. MANY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS INCLUDING ORANGE
COUNTY YOU'RE WORKING ON
AFFECTING THEIR CURRENT AGING
SERVICES IN SUPPORT OF THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING. ARE THE
RESULT OF THIS WORK WE HAVE
RECOGNIZED THE NEED TO DEVELOP
MORE COMPREHENSIVE AND
INTEGRATED CASE MANAGEMENT
MODEL. TO HOLISTICALLY MEET THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF THOSE WE SERVE
OUR DESIRES TO PROVIDE SERVICES
THAT ARE BOTH PERSON CENTERED
AND SIMPLIFY ACCESS TO
COORDINATED RESPONSES. ARE FREE
FOR CUSTOMER EVALUATION PROCESS
THE CAPTAIN COUNTING. BARRIERS
TO CARE FOR NATION. THE CLEAR
THE FOR TO THE END OF BILL FOR
THE- THAT PROVIDE CRITICAL
SUPPORT. FROM SHARING
INFORMATION WITH EACH OTHER. I
THINK FOR EXAMPLE A SITUATION IN
WHICH WE HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL
SEVENTY EIGHT YEARS OF AGE WITH
MULTIPLE SERVICING. SHE LIVES ON
A SMALL MONTHLY RETIREMENT
BENEFIT 5% STRUGGLING TO MEET
THEIR BASIC NEEDS EACH MONTH.
THAT YOU'RE PAYING HER RIGHT
PURCHASING FOOD FOR DECLINING
HEALTH HAS CREATED ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES WITH MAINTAINING A
HEALTHFUL AND OTHER CRITICAL
DAILY ACTIVITIES. TODAY SHE
WOULD NEED TO SEEK SERVICES FROM
UP TO FIVE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
INTO PROVIDERS. INTERACTION WITH
THE SERVICE PROVIDERS WOULD
REQUIRE SOMEONE WHO IS ALREADY
STRUGGLING TO COMMUNICATE WITH
MULTIPLE STAFF MEMBERS AND
SOCIAL WORKERS HAVE BEEN VARIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS REQUIRED THEM TO
NAVIGATE THROUGH A MULTITUDE
ABOUT THE PORTAL. AND DIFFERENT
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS.
ACCORDING SB THIRTEEN TWO CREATE
AN ART. FOR US TO BEGIN
ADDRESSING THE FRAGMENTED
SUPPORT SYSTEM THAT CURRENTLY
EXIST AND I'LL ALLOW FROM LEVEL
OF FLEXIBILITY NEEDED FOR US TO
IMPLEMENT INTEGRATED SERVICES
MODEL FOR BETTER SUPPORT THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF THIS POPULATION-
IT AFFORDED AN OPPORTUNITY
DEVELOP INTEGRATED ASSESSMENT OF
NEED. A COMPREHENSIVE AND
INDIVIDUALIZED CASE PLANS. FIFTY
THIS BILL WITH THE PORT OF THING
CARING FOR AGING POPULATION OF
COOKIE SEMANA WITHOUT REQUIRING
THEM TO GO TO EACH INDIVIDUAL
ACCESS POINT EACH TIME THEY NEED
A SERVICE. ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
WITH MULTIPLE AND COMPLEX NEEDS.
AND ALLOW FOR THE CREATION OF
MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAMS VETERAN
GROUP BOTH GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES
AS WELL COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. MEMBERS OF THE
MPC WOULD HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF MAINTAINING
PRIVACY AND WILL BE REQUIRED TO
SIGN A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING IN ORDER TO
PARTICIPATE. BMO YOU WOULD MAKE
IT VERY CLEAR THAT PRIVACY IS
PARAMOUNT. FINALLY WE WILL BE
WORKING WITH THE SENATE
JUDICIARY CONSULTANTS ON
LANGUAGE AROUND CONSENT. FOR
INFORMATION SHARING AND URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT.
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
A WILL BE MY ON TO WITNESS WERE
TO. GOOD MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I AM HOLLY HAIGLER CEO OF MEALS
ON WHEELS ORANGE COUNTY I AM
ALSO ON THE BOARDS OF DIRECTORS
FOR MEALS ON WHEELS CALIFORNIA
AND FOR MEALS ON WHEELS AMERICA.
MEALS ON WHEELS ORANGE COUNTY
DELIVERS A MILLION MEALS
ANNUALLY TO AT RISK OLDER ADULTS
. IN ORANGE COUNTY WE ALSO
PROVIDE SOCIAL SERVICES SUCH AS
ADULT DAY CARE CASE MANAGEMENT
CARE COORDINATION AND OTHER
PROGRAMS DESIGNED TO HELP OLDER
ADULTS REMAIN SAFE IN THEIR
HOMES. AND THE COMMUNITY THEY
LIVE. AT MEALS ON WHEELS- SEE WE
PARTNER WITH THE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPALITIES AS WELL AS SENIOR
HOUSING MANAGED CARE HEALTH
PLANS HOSPITALS AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS SIR VULNERABLE
OLDER ADULTS. AND PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR CAREGIVERS WHO NEED
A CONSISTENT AND ONGOING PLAN OF
CARE. IN MY EXPERIENCE OLDER
ADULTS UTILIZING THE SERVICES OF
MEALS ON WHEELS THOSE BE COULD
ALSO BENEFIT FROM ADDITIONAL
CARE IN OTHER AREAS OF THEIR
LIVES. SERVICES SUCH AS HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION LEGAL ADVICE AND
OTHER ACTIVITIES OF DAILY LIVING
BECOME MORE CHALLENGING AS WE
AGE. REQUIRING A NEW
INTRODUCTION DETERMINATION OF
NEED AND SEPARATE CASE PLAN FOR
EACH AND EVERY SERVICE PROVIDED
IS AN UNNECESSARY BARRIER TO
CARE. WE RECOGNIZE THAT VARIOUS
SERVICES REQUIRE STRONG
COORDINATION BY THOSE WHO
PROVIDE THE CRITICAL PROGRAM
THAT OLDER ADULTS RELY ON FOR
THEIR SAFETY INDEPENDENCE AND
WELLBEING. SB THIRTEEN FORTY TWO
WILL SUPPORT THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING EMPHASIS ON PROVIDING
PERSON CENTRED SERVICES AND
IMPROVED ACCESS. IT WILL HELP
OLDER ADULTS IN NEED OF
ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE RECEIVE A
MULTITUDE OF COORDINATED SUPPORT
IN A STREAMLINED MANNER WHILE
ALSO PRESERVING THEIR PRIVACY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR TO OUR
WITNESSES TODAY AND SUPPORT THIS
BILL WE WILL MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY TWO WILL BEGIN
HEARING ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
. ANYONE HERE. WISHING TO STATE
THEIR POSITION ON THE MEASURE
SEE NON A WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT LINE.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. IF
YOU LIKE TO COME IN SUPPORT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO FIRST WE'LL
GO TO LINE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN
MEMBERS NOT ALL OF THE SUPER
FROM ELP AND MARK MORE ON
BEHALF CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JOSH DUGGAR ON BEHALF
OF URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF VENTURA COUNTY
ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT
TO THE TO LINE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I WAS SUGGESTING GARRETT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY BOARD.
THANK YOU. AT THE TIME THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANY SCHEDULED
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL SO WE'LL BEGIN WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE IN THIS ROOM. SEEN NINE
WILL MOVE ON TO THE TO
OPPOSITION IT WAITING TO- THE
STATE'S POSITION ON THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT LINE.
YOU LIKE TO COME IN OPPOSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND THERE'S NO ONE IN
Q. OKAY THANK YOU- I. WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR AND APPRECIATE
YOUR FOCUS ON PROVIDING MORE
INTEGRATED COORDINATED CARE TO
OUR OLDER ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA-
BEATS AND- AS MENTIONED IN THE
ANALYSIS- IT IS IMPORTANT WE
HAVE ÁP. BALANCE BALANCES WILL
MORE COORDINATED SERVICES WITH
THE NEED TO IMPLEMENT INDIVIDUAL
BOB HALL THERE ARE CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION MAY BE SHARED AND
OBTAIN THEIR CONSENT TO THAT
INFORMATION SHARING UNDERSTAND
WILL BE WORKING ON THAT EXACT
LANGUAGE IN THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH US- DO ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS COMMENTS VIA CENTER
PANDION THE CALM WATER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND SIR BATES I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE- WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE WITH
THIS BILL AND- TO ALLOW
BASICALLY DIFFERENT AGENCIES
WORK TOGETHER THROUGH THIS MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM. I THINK WAS
BECAUSE THIS WAS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS ABOUT PRIVACY ISSUES OF
COURSE WERE DEALING WITH SENIORS
WHO ARE ADULTS AND- AND- I'M
SURE WE PROTECT OUR PRIVACY SO I
KNOW YOU'LL BE ADDRESSING SOME
HILL MADE HIS ISSUES AND YOU DO
SHERRY BUT- I DID WANT IT SIR.
MAYBE ASK QUESTIONS REGARDING
THE PRIVACY ISSUES- SO- IN TERMS
OF- THE PRIVACY RULES WHICH- AT
LEAST YOUR INTENT- WITH THIS I
MEAN. SO THE MULTI DISPLAY TEAM
GETS GETS TOGETHER- I GUESS
WOULD THIS BE ON A- YES NEED TO
KNOW BASIS AND OTHERS I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE
PARTICULARLY TO THE PERSON BEING
SERVED EXACTLY WHO'S- GOING TO
YOU KNOW. UNDER WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCES THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION MAY BE SHARED WHAT
TYPE OF INFORMATION RIGHT SO-
AND I START THINKING ABOUT MY
YEAH MYSPACE'S PRIVACY IS A
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL. SO SOMEONE
MAY SIGN A DEAL WAVERED IT SAYS
OF COURSE YOU KNOW- FOR PRIVACY
AND WE GET HIT BY AND SO FORTH
BUT A LATE WITHIN THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM BUT EVEN WITHIN THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IF YOU'RE NOT
INVOLVED IN ACTUAL PATIENT CARE
OF THE PATIENT YOU SHOULD BE
GETTING. THEIR HEALTH
INFORMATION RIGHT BECAUSE YOU'RE
NOT ACTUALLY PARTLY INVOLVED
EVEN THOUGH YOU MAY BE WORKING
IN THE HOSPITAL AND SO FORTH. SO
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER TO THEIR
THOUGHTS IN TERMS OF. FOR THE
AND THE T. THAT. HOW YOU
INSURED- WHAT YOU THINK MAYBE
THE- THE BOUNDARIES FOR SHARING
OF INFORMATION WITHIN THE M. D.
T. TO PREVENT- I GUESS-
VENTURING OF INFORMATION PEOPLE
WHO ACTUALLY AREN'T INVOLVED IN
PROVIDING SERVICES RIGHT AND I
REALIZE THAT SOME OF IT MAYBE
ALSO BECAUSE- YOU'RE EXPLORING
WHETHER THEY NEED A SERVICE SO.
MAYBE THEY'RE NOT RECEIVING
SERVICE YET BUT- BUT BASICALLY
LIMITED AND I GUESS YOU COULD
SAY NEED TO NOTATE BASIS AND-
I'M SURE THE DISTRICT MAYBE CAN
HELP WORK OUT THE LANGUAGE FOR
HOW HOW YOU WOULD ACTUALLY BUT
THEN THE CODE. BUT THE BUT AT
AND I KNOW YOU SO I HAVE
EXPERIENCE AS A SOCIAL WORKER
AND SOME OF THESE ISSUES WELL
BUT MAYBE YOU CAN TRY TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THAT TO BE HELPFUL. FOR
ME I THINK IT'S PROBABLY THE OUR
DOCTOR PAN SENATOR PAM. BUT IT
GOES TO THE INTAKE PROCESS
ITSELF AND IT USUALLY HAVING
BEEN I A DID A GREAT DEAL ABOUT
WHEN I WAS SOCIAL WORKER. THERE
ARE FORMS THAT ARE FILLED OUT SO
IT WOULD BE THEY'LL MAKE GIVING
CONSENT. BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT
THE FORM THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
FILL OUT WHICH WOULD BE MULTI
OVER THE THREE DISCIPLINES THAT.
THEY WOULD HAVE TO HAVE A VERY
IN DEPTH CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT
IT MEANT IF THEY WERE CONSENTING
AND IN PARTICULAR IT IS ALL
ABOUT THE HEALTH ISSUES THE
PRIVACY THAT. HAVE TO DO WITH
WHAT PROJECTS HIPPA SO I WOULD
SEE A FORM THAT ACTUALLY. I HAD
ABOUT CONSENT ON IT AND THEN
EXPLAINING WHAT THAT. MEANT TO
THE INDIVIDUAL WHICH HOUSING
INTAKE SO WORKER YOU DO. SPEND A
LOT OF TIME. ON THE FACE TO
FACE. WHEN YOU'RE DO. IT ONLINE.
I WOULD SAY THAT. COULD BE PART
PROBLEMATIC IF IT'S NOT DONE
FACE TO FACE. WE HAVEN'T REALLY
CONFRONTED THAT QUESTION BUT I
THINK THAT SOMETHING THAT. IN
TERMS OF THIS WHOLE DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE PRIVACY NEEDS TO COME
UP. GOT A FORM AND YOU'RE GOING
OVER IT WITH YOUR CLIENT. AND
WHAT IT MEANS THAT EACH ONE OF
THE AREAS THAT YOU'RE PROVIDING
INFORMATION. I SEE THE HEALTH
ISSUES HAVE A LOT TO DO WITH
NUTRITION OKAY. AND WHETHER AND
THE MEDICATIONS THAT ARE BEING.
GIVEN AND TAKEN. IT WOULD BE THE
I THINK THAT. THE CONSENT OF THE
INDIVIDUAL TO SAY. I HAVE A HIGH
BLOOD PRESSURE PROBLEM THAT I'M
TAKING THIS. AND IF THEY DON'T
WISH TO DISCUSS THAT BUT THAT
HAS A LOT TO DO WITH NUTRITION.
THEN THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS
LEFT WITH THE CLIENT THE
INDIVIDUAL. IF THEY WANT TO
REVEAL THAT. BUT IT SEEMS TO ME
IF YOU'RE GOING TO EACH ONE OF
THESE INDIVIDUALLY. THESE
PROGRAMS YOU HAVE THAT SAME
ISSUE. IDEA BECAUSE WHAT I WOULD
DO IS AN INTAKE SUPERVISOR. WE
WOULD INTERVIEW THE PERSON. THEY
NEEDED X. Y. NZ WE'D HAVE TO
SEND THEM TO ALL THOSE
DIFFERENT. AGENCIES TO GET THAT
HELP. AND THEY WERE GOING
THROUGH THE SAME INTERVIEW
PROCESS THE SAME CONSENT. SO
THIS IS PUTTING IT ALL WITH ONE
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S GOING TO DO THE
INTERVIEW AND I'M ASSUMING. THAT
THAT TRIAGE WOULD COME WHEN THE
PERSON APPLIES. FOR SOME SORT OF
ASSISTANCE. THE OPRAH APPRECIATE
ANSWER I THINK- AND I AGREE WITH
YOU THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SOMEONE
HAVE TO PHYSICALLY GO. ANSWER
THE SAME QUESTIONS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN FOR EACH DIFFERENT PROGRAM
AND THAT'S PROBABLY WHAT THE MDT
WILL HELP ADDRESS. I THINK THE
PART THAT. PERHAPS COULD USE A
CLARIFICATION RIGHT BECAUSE AT
LEAST BUT THAT'S LIKE. WHEN YOU
WENT EACH PROGRAM YOU KNEW THAT
THAT PROGRAM TO GET THE
INFORMATION YOU CAN AND YOU
MIGHT DECIDE REFUSE THE ANSWER
FOR ONE PROGRAMS YOU THINK
WASN'T RELEVANT TO THEM THAN THE
OTHER SO NOW YOU HAVE ONE AND
TWO. SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THEY KNOW THAT OKAY IF I DO THE
ONE INTAKE EXACTLY WHO'S GOING
TO GO TO. AND ALSO THAT. AND
I'M- AND AGAIN NOT TRYING TO PUT
THE ENTIRE BURDEN ON THE PERSON
RECEIVING THE SERVICES THAT
THERE WILL BE A BEST JUDGMENT
THAT. INFORMATION THAT IS
NECESSARY TO BE SHARED THAT THEY
MAY HAVE GIVEN ON THE INTAKE.
WOULD NOT TO BE SHARED WITH
AGENCIES WERE THAT WOULD BE
RELEVANT TO THEM RIGHT SO THAT
WE WOULD DO AN INTAKE. YOU'D BE
GATHERING THIS INFORMATION BUT
ONLY THE- INFORMATION THAT'S
NECESSARY. FOR THE OTHER
AGENCIES WHO MAY BE PART OF ME
IN THE M. B. T. IT'S ADDRESS SO
THAT WE CAN GET THEM THE WHOLE.
SET OF SERVICES THAT ONLY THE
ONES THAT WERE PARTICULARLY
RELEVANT ARE NECESSARY FOR THAT-AGENCY TO HAVE WOULD BE SURE TO
NOT MISS OF THE ENTIRE INTAKE
WHICH MAY BE MORE COMPREHENSIVE.
IN ORDER TO TRY TO COVER ALL THE
DIFFERENT BASES. SELL SELL LEADS
SO HOPEFULLY IS YOUR JUDICIARY.
THAT THAT CAN BE SORTED OUT BUT
THAT IS THAT. IS WHAT I'M SAYING
MAKE IT. ARE YOU AGREEMENT DOES
THAT MAKE SENSE YES YES OKAY ALL
RIGHT I'M COMING IN FOR LET'S
SAY HELP. WITH CLUB. YOU KNOW
HOUSEKEEPING ON THE SERVICES I
NEED BECAUSE I'M NOT ABLE TO.
PARTICIPATE COMPLETELY AN
AVERAGE. EVERYDAY OUT DAILY
ACTIVITIES WILL THEY DON'T NEED
TO KNOW. HOW MUCH MONEY OF THE
BANK. YOU KNOW RIGHT FINANCIAL
LITERACY GOES ALONG WITH THIS
TOO WHICH IS ALWAYS BEEN A
PROBLEM IN DOING INTAKE ARE THEY
ELIGIBLE ACTUALLY. RIGHT SO. YES
WE WOULD CERTAINLY ADDRESS THAT
BECAUSE I AGREE TOTALLY. NOT NOT
WHEN I THINK THAT I SIGNED IN IN
MY EXPERIENCE- THERE'S SUCH A
DESPERATE NEED. THEY'RE WILLING
TO SAY ANYTHING ANY REAL WE
DON'T WANT TO HAVE A- ON THE
RED. THAT SHOULDN'T BE PART OF
PART. SERVICE THAT THEY NEED AND
I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO
CREATE A FIVE. OF SOME SORT.
OKAY NOT THAT THAT THAT'S VERY
HELPFUL BECAUSE IT COULD BE AS
YOU ACTUALLY GAVE A FAIRLY AND-
INTAKE BECAUSE MAYBE THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU NEED THAT YOU
HAVE SHARE FINANCIAL DATA BUT
THERE MAY BE ANOTHER SERVICE
THAT BE HELPFUL TO YOU. THAT
DOESN'T NEED TO KNOW THAT. JUST
BECAUSE HE GAVE ON INTAKE THEY
DON'T. THEY DON'T NEED TO KNOW
THAT RIGHT THEY JUST NEED TO
KNOW THE STUFF THEY NEED TO
KNOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE CENTER A THINK THEY
NEED TO KNOW IT'S A GREAT. IT'S
A GREAT. CUT COVER IT ALL DON'T
YOU. WHAT WOULD YOU REALLY NEED
TO KNOW. OKAY RIGHT. WELL THANK
YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL TO PROCEED I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR PAN AM CENTER
COMMON PURCHASE OF QUESTION FROM
YOU GUYS. AT THE RISK OF
SOUNDING REDUNDANT VERY- HAPPY
TO KNOW AS IT WAS IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT THE LANGUAGE
AROUND CONSENT IS GOING TO BE
HASHED OUT IN- JUDICIARY. I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU BUT DURING
COLD IT I HAPPEN TO WATCH THAT
MOVIE I CARE A LOT. AND IT'S-
INTENSE IN TERMS OF HOW THE
ELDERLY FOLKS AT CAN BE AND ARE
ROUTINELY TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF.
YEAH A LOT OF IT HAS TO DO WITH-
THEIR INFORMATION AND HOW IT IS
SHARED AND SO- JUST ALSO HOPING
THAT THERE'S CONTINUED
DISCUSSION AND THOUGHT AROUND
CHECKS AND BALANCES BECAUSE I DO
THINK THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHAT. THE CLIENT NEEDS.
AND THEN WHAT PEOPLE THINK THE
CLIENT NEEDS AND OFTEN TIMES WE
PUT A LOT IN THAT LATTER BUCKET
BECAUSE SOMEONE IS ELDERLY
BECAUSE MAYBE THEY SEEM
FORGETFUL OR BE YOU KNOW BECAUSE
LIKE YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU
NEED- YOU KNOW I. MOTHER SAYS
THAT A LOT. WHEN I'M TALKING TO
HER- AND THE REALITY IS THAT
MANY ELDERLY FOLKS DO NOT WHAT
THEY NEED AND THEY DO KNOW WHAT
THEY WANT AND SO HOW DO WE- MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S A FRAMEWORK IN
PLACE. THAT DOESN'T TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THEM THAT DOESN'T
DISMISS OR MARGINALIZE THE
THINGS THAT THEY BELIEVE ARE
IMPORTANT FOR THEM- BECAUSE THE
OTHER PART THAT WE KNOW. IS THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF MONEY TO BE
MADE OFF THE BACKS OF THE
ELDERLY- AND SO ALSO HOW DO WE
CREATE A FRAMEWORK THAT ALSO IS
VERY HONEST ABOUT THAT BECAUSE
OFTEN TIMES PEOPLE MAY. SUGGEST
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES- BECAUSE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES ARE YOU JUST
BECAUSE THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE MONEY OFF THE BACKS OF
THE SENIOR AND SO. THAT CAN ALSO
COMPLICATE THINGS SO HOPING THAT
SOME OF THAT IS ALSO INFUSED IN
SOME OF THE DISCUSSIONS THAT
HAPPEN- ENGINEERS. AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL OKAY THANK
YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS WITH MEMBERS THREE
NINE OKAY. OUR CENTER BATES ARE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. WITH
YOU THANK YOU FOR THE SUB. VERY
ROBUST DEBATE I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT. ISSUE THAT'S BEEN
BROUGHT UP BECAUSE SOMETIMES
SENIORS STARTED TO GIVE TOO MUCH
INFORMATION THAT THEY DON'T NEED
TO GO. INTO THAT CAN OPEN THE
DOOR TO OF PRIVACY BREACHES AND
ALSO. I TAKING ADVANTAGE SO WE
WILL MAKE SURE AS WE GET TO
JUDICIARY THAT. WE ARE VERY
CAREFUL AND ENSURE THAT WE DO
HAVE THOSE FIREWALLS AND HAVE IT
CONTAINED ISSUE ALL UP YOU KNOW
HAVE INDICATED AND I'M CERTAINLY
AND OUT. OF THE CORNER SO I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT YOUR AYE VOTE
AND APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES ARE WE HAVE A
MOTION BY. A SENATOR HAN ON THIS
MEASURE. AND THE MEASURE OF THE
MAN THE MOTION IS TO DO PASSED
THE FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE INTERESTED SHURI. AND
CONSULTING Q. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. OUR DATA. I FEDERAL I
JONES. JONES I CRITICALLY FOR
THE I. FROM OTHER HÌNH HOWEVER I
CAN I CAN I THINK YOU AND I WANT
TO MENTION THANK YOU TO OUR
SPONSORS TODAY AND HARD
WITNESSES CAME A LONG WAY TO GET
TO GET HERE TODAY SO THANK YOU
ALL OF COURSE OF COURSE THANK
YOU AT THE AT THE VOTE IS FIVE
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT AND UP
WHAT UP NEXT WE HAVE AGENDA ITEM
FIVE AS J. R. EIGHT BY CENTER
COME AGAIN- AND- JUST FEEL FREE
TO PRESENT YOUR BILL WHEN YOU
ARE READY. GOOD AFTERNOON. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT S. J.
R. EIGHT WHICH CALLS ON CONGRESS
TO EXPAND THE SOCIAL SECURITY
DISABILITY INSURANCE PROGRAM TO
ALLOW CHILDHOOD DISABILITY
RECIPIENTS THE RIGHT TO MARRY
WHOMEVER THEY CHOOSE WITHOUT THE
THREAT OF TERMINATION TO THE
BENEFITS SOCIAL SECURITY IS THE
MOST EXTENSIVE SAFETY NET
PROGRAM AND UNITED STATES WERE
EXPENSIVE HEALTH INSURANCE CAN
BE AND AFFORDABLE FOR MANY.
DISABILITY HEALTH BENEFITS OFFER
COMPREHENSIVE SUPPORT FOR SEVERE
CHRONIC ILLNESSES AND
DISABILITIES AS AN ALTERNATIVE
TO EXPENSIVE COMMERCIAL COVERAGE
ROUND SIXTY FIVE MILLION
ELIGIBLE WORKING AMERICANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES DEPEND ON THE
SOCIAL SECURITY DISABILITY
INSURANCE PROGRAM FOR MONTHLY
LIFESAVING BENEFITS THIS PROGRAM
IS A LIFELINE FOR MANY SOME DRAW
SOCIAL SECURITY AS THE AGE WHILE
OTHERS HAVE RELIED ON LIFESAVING
SUPPORT. SINCE BIRTH. USE YOUR
DISABLED BEFORE THE AGE OF
TWENTY TO QUALIFY FOR BENEFITS
THROUGH A PARENT'S EARNINGS AND
ARE KNOWN AS CHILDHOOD
DISABILITY RECIPIENTS
UNFORTUNATELY INEQUITIES WITHIN
THE PROGRAM PENALIZE CHILDHOOD
DISABILITY RECIPIENTS WHO PURSUE
A LEGAL MARRIAGE WITH A NON
DISABLED PARTNER. CHILDHOOD
DISABILITY RECIPIENTS FACE THE
THREAT OF TERMINATION OR
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION TO THE
BENEFITS IF THEY MARRY A PERSON
WHO IS NOT DISABLED. THOSE WHO
RELY ON BENEFITS FOR INCOME
SUPPORT OR HEALTH COVERAGE MUST
DECIDE BETWEEN CONTINUED
LIFESAVING ASSISTANCE OR
MARRYING THEIR SIGNIFICANT
OTHER. THIS ONE THE SYSTEM HAS
DISCOURAGED DISABLED PEOPLE FROM
MARRYING THE LOVE OF THEIR LIFE.
EVERY CITIZEN IS GUARANTEED THE
RIGHT TO MARRY WHOM THEY CHOOSE
HOWEVER MARRIAGE PRESENTS A
FINANCIAL BARRIER FAR TOO STEEP
FOR A SIGNIFICANT POPULATION OF
DISABLED AMERICANS IF IT CAUSES
THE BENEFITS TO CEASE. CONGRESS
MUST AMEND THE CURRENT
DISCRIMINATORY STRUCTURE OF THE
SOCIAL SECURITY DISABILITY
INSURANCE PROGRAM. TO GUARANTEE
CHILDHOOD DISABILITY RECIPIENTS
THE RIGHT TO MARRY WHOMEVER THEY
CHOOSE AND RETAIN THE LIFESAVING
BENEFITS THEY HAVE HAD
THROUGHOUT THEIR ENTIRE LIFE.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. J. R. EIGHT IS A
LEASH AT A USHA LEWIS WITH THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS EDUCATION AND
DEFENSE FUND. MONTH MODERATED WE
HAVE OF THE WITNESS ON THE LINE. HELLO NAME OF THE WITH A VERY
. HI PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND PLEASE
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS EDUCATION AND
DEFENSE FUND STRONGLY WHAT
HAPPENED TO THAT THEY ARE.
SOCIAL SECURITY BENEFITS OUR TV
FOR MANY PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES BUT TO THE CURRENT
ADELINE HOW YOU THINK IT'S OFTEN
CANNOT MARRY WITHOUT. THE CABLE
BILL HI. BACKSPLASH SOCIAL
BENEFIT SEARCH ADULT. I RECEIVED
A PHONE. FIVE A MONTHLY FIVE ONE
MEDICARE THE SPECIAL THE
MEDICAID UNDER STATUTE ACT FOR
ON A BE SENATE. I FIVE ANOTHER
SOURCE PROGRAM OFF THE HALF WITH
THERE. THE PEOPLE AT THE END OF
THE DISABILITY ACT TO HEALTH FOR
NATIONWIDE. PONTIFICAL OUTDATED
IN ON THE RIGHT. THEY ALSO RISK
RELIGIOUS FREEDOM PREVENT PEOPLE
TAKING PART IN THE HOTEL JEFF
RESEARCH SIGNIFICANCE ONE
NINETEEN. A COUPLE OF OFF OF THE
BARRIERS FOR MAKING HARDER FOR
DISABLED. FINALLY BEING UNABLE
MERRY IS ANOTHER THE MAN.
OBSTACLE THANK YOU WITH
DISABILITIES AND BEING INTO INTO
THAT. THE COMMISSION VERY
IMPORTANT THE POLITICAL
COMMUNITY START AT HAS BEEN IN
TOUCH WITH ACROSS THE STATE
MAYBE YEARS TO BE. I HAVE NOT.
YEAH LIKE. HE WILL DISABILITY
THAT THEY MIGHT WANT BUT A LOT
OF BOB IS A CANNELLA I PLEDGE
WHEN DESTRUCTIVE CAL. HAS
INTRODUCED EIGHT FOUR OH FIVE
INCOME. THE TO CHANGE FEDERAL
AND THE FACT. HI CARE EIGHT
INTEL TO HELP PASSAGE OF HR
DISQUALIFIED. FIFTY STATUS FOR
FASTER EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TODAY WILL BE MOVE
FORWARD WITH A PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE BEGINNING
HERE AND- TWO. SEEN ON OCT WE
MOVE WE WILLBE MOVING ON TO
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMON LINE IN
SUPPORT. IF YOU LIKE TO COME AND
SUPPORT ME PRESS ONE IN THERE AT
THIS TIME. JUST A MOMENT.
FSO GO TO LINE NINE OR ELEVEN
ONE ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL
NINE ELEVEN YOUR LINES OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS HELEN
MINARD I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
S. J. R. EIGHT I HAVE A CO
WORKER WHO HAS HAD TO CALL OFF
THEIR WEDDING BECAUSE OF THIS
HORRIBLE ALL OF THE AND IT HAS
BEEN DEVASTATING FOR THEM. I
URGE YOU TO PLEASE PASSED SJR
EIGHT OUT OF COMMITTEE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND JUST A REMINDER
WERE TAKING UP POSITIONS ON THE
MEASURE ADD NAME ORGANIZATION.
AND OPPOSITION ON THE MEASURE.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS DIANE THE SOLEMN A PRIVATE
CITIZEN I HAVE DEAR FRIENDS
AFFECTED BY THIS ARCHAIC POLICY
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT. OF J. R.
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU. I
NEXT TO LINE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WHAT THE CHURCH IN
SUPPORT OF STR EIGHT. ONE
SUPPORT THANK YOU THAT IS A. I
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS LAURIE LONG AND I AM
PERSONALLY AFFECTED BY THE FACT
PASSED LAWS I HAD TO CALL LAW.
MY FIANCE AND I HAD TO CALL OFF
OUR WEDDING AND MAKE THAT
DEVASTATING DECISION IN ORDER TO
HELP KEEP ME ALIVE SO I AM IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT XKR EIGHT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO GO TO
LINE. FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINES OPEN. YES I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER
MAIN BERNAMA STRONG SUPPORTER
FOR. AND THE FACT THAT- UP THE
ONE FOR ME. THANK YOU. AT THIS
TIME THERE'S NO NOTHING Q. THANK
YOU HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS OF WE WILL MOVE ON
TO- LEE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
AB AND CURRENTLY WE DON'T HAVE
ANY KNOWN OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
SO LET'S BEGIN WITH PUBLIC
COMMON OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
. SEEN NONE WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TOP OF PUBLIC COMMENT LINE IN
OPPOSITION TO AS G. R. EIGHT-
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE R.
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WITH JUST
FINE OPPOSITION. SURE IF YOU
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF
THE DAY ARE EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AT THE
TIME IS NOW WINNING QUEUE. OKAY
THANK YOU. I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS OR
COMMENTS ON MY END BUT- MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE
TO. ADD TO THIS ON THIS MEASURE
NO. INTERPRET THE BILL. ARE WE
HAVE A RESOLUTION. OKAY WELL. A
CENTER COME AGAIN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENTED IN A RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
PAN- THE MOTION IS. IT BE
ADOPTED ORDER TO THIRD READING
OUR ONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. HURTADO I FIR
DATA I JONES. JONES ADEQUATE AS
THE. KAMLAGER HI COMMITTEE I HIT
ALL RIGHT IN. FOR DIFFERENT.
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
PLACE THE SENATE JOINT
RESOLUTION ON CALL TO ALLOW ALL
MEMBERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE
. AND WE WILL OF BOTH THE ROLE
OPEN JUST ON THIS LAST MEASURE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU.
OKAY AT THIS MOMENT ARE WE WILL
GO AHEAD AND OPEN. UP TO BE-
BILLS THERE ARE ON CALL FOR
LIFTING THE CALLS I SHOULD SAY
OF AND CONTROL TO Q. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL- AS J. R. EIGHT
FASTENER CABALLERO AYE THE
MOTION IS BE ADOPTED ORDER TO
THIRD READING CORTELLI. COURTESY
I. THE THAT HAD FIVE ZERO THE
VOTERS FIVE ZERO AND FACT A
MEASURE IS OUT AND THAT
CONCLUDES OUR- HEARING TODAY FOR
THE SENATE HUMAN- SERVICES
COMMITTEE AND WE THANK EVERYONE
FOR PARTICIPATING FOR YOUR
PATIENCE IN YOUR COOPERATION OUR
AGENDA HAS CONCLUDED AND THIS
MEETING IS OFFICIALLY ENTERED.